halo is it updates you're looking for
you're in luck halo 5s latest free
expansion gives you new maps weapons and
references to halo 2 i'm kate and this
is your game spot news update halo 5
guardians latest update infinities
armory was released on wednesday adding
new maps for x and more the new maps are
Riptide arena and urban war zone assault
while a halo 2 era battle rifle is one
of the featured rex others include rare
variants of the carbine rifle as well as
a new Achilles armor set infinity's
armory is halo 5s 3rd free expansion
following battle of shadow and light in
November 2015 and the cartographers gift
in December 2015 developer 343
Industries has pledged to support halo 5
with new content through summer 2016 are
you going to jump back into halo 5 to
check out the infinities armory content
let me know in the comments we'll come
find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot's